do do do do do Una stooping
swollen when I stupid what does not yet
I have to get a snack first actually know
what almost all start to Q
I'll start with you and see what happens I'm
supposed to wait until reserve and now I've
been told dinner's not for three hours so
I'm having a snack
crackers and sausage portion
sausage and crackers my God is so good home
churches down what's down
I'm queuing cartel money is down
why did some did did must say some something
stupid about her or something
I don't know how loud is it going to be
dududududu
Mercer TV show a game I don't know as a TV
show
I want to join Sam's for you
I'm crunching in your ear I'm sorry there's
like four people here
I hope they're taking a break we're going to
do some more letting stuff later
what do 2 season 2 is on Netflix I did not
know this
I don't know
I'm going to play games for next 3 hours
after all that talk about doing more with
your life it's Friday night give me a ring
maybe not all three of those hours will see
my wife is going to make dinner and then she
changed her why Minds on me and she said
she's going to change it and make it 3 hours
time a male dinner
god dammit they finished up my favorite one
again is there probably going to lose
cup with coffee for you yes
play Ricky should I do a Ricky just for the
fun of it
the toys that again except to me
are these guys are going to need Mana
what do what do Power Crystal again you
don't have any he's there's no stunts here
no stuns don't pick a stunner bro she's got
a silence that sucks
that means I have to get bkb I didn't think
I was going to have to but now I do how many
bkb anyway because it is old
I'm going to be better bkb or
a Lincoln when you guys think it'll be KB or
a Lincoln here I don't know
Zeus conference in Troy
hey Crystal how's it going and crystals dog
you're so much cuter than slardar sorry I
was ugly
I need to get you a new scepter though your
scepter is kind of like old school
crystal scepter is kind of old school on me
are you going to catch me
uh oh here we go
music out loud that LOL oh shit and I can
help him get first Blood
no yeah they're not dumb
dumb read to them anyway
give me the first Bud phuc yea I mean
something else
dog from Detroit do it all yeah we got to
pick up with the name the dog and we're
going to need my dog
dog from Detroit Detroit Rock City
snowball deny dammit yay
uh oh Mister Magic
I'm going to need that in the dangerous Lane
here
it doesn't matter 50 cock Americans you
definitely can
indefinitely and you can definitely joke
like us us Americans
a smarter I love you thank you sir
that was nice Thunder game you give me
healing thingy
and I'll deny for you there buddy Chromecast
Chromecast monkey concussion
oh damn it that hurt that hurt
hey girl hey I need to get the freezer
it's not going to hurt me you can't hurt me
I'm impervious to your attacks
if I got my freezer I got my freezer going
I gots me the freezes do give me a deny
their slardar come on dude
show me how to deny my friend
going to die I'm going to die I'm going to
die if I'm not careful going to die
gaming and work and teaching you know what
it's hard I don't I don't balance it we
talkin about
I'm going to be kind of do a one a little
bit
I do game it's hard though because I just
said I was like I went on a huge tirade
about you know doing more with your time
than just gaming and stuff and it's hard
it's hard to find balance I owe Ally
I think but you know it's Friday night at
the end of the day. It is already fuck
how to say how is old already
he shot that is not fair you know why
because what's his face
at the shop has been handing over his ex be
pictures of a sex that's like really
dangerous
get me out of here God dammit
he's only eight already I've only died once
it'll be known
this this is a structure is letting him have
all the XP that's going to be like really
dangerous
but emotional and I Dean he's by himself
because he his instructor buddy is like
letting him get all the XP
cuz he's playing it like a traditional
support no that's okay though
imma imma get him imma get him
he's not he's level 9 cuz he's only cuz it's
just him in the lane he gets all the
experience
he's getting all the experience from god
dammit
this is his attack is really bad did you see
that he isn't stupid ass
yeah he's got torrent which is really bad
God is getting results already
we can't touch that CI we cannot come
anywhere near him
oh shit are you going to die I got going to
die
what is stupid Turks ear she see if
has two towers 4000 or so I've been playing
since beta
I'm not proud I'm not proud I'm also not
good cuttlefish risotto
and that dangerous isn't cuttlefish Rosetta
dangerous
how's it going Timo
who's your sister Jojo okay, I got to get I
got to get even with mocha hair
I'm going to kill him
oh man I didn't deny it after all
God damn it it's a stupid fucking range he's
got so much range
his stupid like his stupid like whatever
cleave his cleave range is like 11:00 has an
1100 Cleveland fucking 11:00
that's like insane it's so insane
yeah I'm going to go fight with the rest of
team I can't go anywhere away from the team
at all of course but
do do
Google overfed absolutely yeah he's coming
he's going to come in there he's going to
destroy him matv Darius
I just have to get my old I have to get my
full oats
good job guys
good job I don't how I can I can clean up
later I'll clean up the mess later
I'm a really good like I-5 new car at the
end
yeah I'm just going to I'll just I'll just
bring on the nukes later
father and I are kinda under level the exit
or not is Queens been cleaning up thank God
oh here we go here we go we got to help our
fellow countrymen
I got a double kill here
200 Health to attributes it's so pretty my
old
mouth is so pretty yes we do I agree
to Ramona nice
wait what
and I miss
they're waiting for me to make bb-8 I guess
I got to get out of here
is way too hot this is too hot
we need that I need that
Ariel
are we going to die I got to going to die
he's going to Die Here Comes we got in VIs
I need my my ex super speed attack here's
that that
I'm bad
don't do anyone think that I'm good at. I am
not I could possibly be the world's worst
DOTA player
but I mean in terms of like actual do
anything I buy turbo Turbo is a totally
different game. Although I can fucking stop
with Nature's and turbo like pretty much
every time I had four straight runs back so
far I haven't lost with Nature's the last
six games I played with Nature's I want
everyone so far
I have a new bill that actually made a guide
for it and everything cuz it's fun all right
here we go
let's see if this guy is dumb enough to keep
pushing that Tower before I
nope he's not so I'm not going to blow it
all he is
got to be really careful with Crystal cuz
her old is the same as d p is like right
next to it
out here comes Coke
I don't have sneaky upness I don't have
sneaky sneaky Eunice yet
so I'm just going to sit here and pretend
like little old me
damn it I don't want to give up my position
I want to like catch him off guard
you did I didn't have to blow my old
that's the resistance who
jochi jochi I don't know what's going on
here his name is sister
whose name is Claire I know what you do here
oh my God will make it intelligence
yeah I mean this
yay Roy
why didn't you pick that up wind breaker
I'm being sneaky I mean sneaky as much as I
can
I'm kind of playing a support even though I
don't know oh oh
give me a teepee scroll please stat
I guess they don't care about their Tower
I'm going to take their teepee point I do
not have an escape this is extremely
dangerous
oh
326 gold for that for that I haven't tried
laying people loved it but I haven't tried
it
oh here we go here we go it's on
hey how are you going to rush hour
super speed Crystal this is a meme this is a
meme
that's right that's right suck it you dead
drow
you just died at the hands of Crystal Maiden
you die
meanwhile
oh shit we lost the computer. We lost up
here and now you shall die
I have tried me I need to Riley cuz I hear
it's it's easier and it has a better story
my stepson keeps telling me all the time the
Arcana
it's so much better I guess I should believe
him
should I said you blink stomp you know what
is crazy funny on her blinks dump I've ever
seen Crystal bling stop anniversary so
absolutely that's why I love her hermana
boots for like a zoo steam like this
horseshit yeah early-game hermana boost
totally they don't give them even know
they're like all the Sunday Lost Lake where
are we losing cuz Crystal and they don't
they don't know they don't know how big a
deal it is
it's it's not uncommon
what the fuk was that how did I try to that
well I died three times Bowser
and her mom is really amazing
I kind of think I should probably get this
if you get this I have Scotty you know what
should I do it I am Scotty turns Crystal
Maiden into drow
if you do if you like this we have a Zeus to
you so it's just like
my breaker I think you should kiss my ass
that's what I think
hey hey hey sniper if you're watching this
video fuck you
I got the I cut it myself it's mine
yeah
I see if I'm going to make it before he dies
nope he's dead
nope he's dead he be dead
I hear I get you some other stuff you can
get this
I like my my breaker I'm going to get I have
Scotty and my breaker I maybe one kick ass
mother phone
look at that look at that look at that
ranged attack damage from Miss Miss Crystal
people think I can't be a Carrie bullshit
bulshit watch this watch a fast you want to
be me
oh I need critz the only thing I can do
better than that is Chris all right I'm
going to have Scotty and Chris
I am
this is why you play Turbo if youplay Turbo
if you build a crystal like this in regular
Mr do that you're a bad person
where is never
I promise I don't have an escape that's kind
of dangerous
yeah I really don't have an escape I don't
have an escape so I got to be careful
and I have no way to get away except for my
teleport oh shit
somebody getting really messed up Sardar
that seems kind of dangerous
I'm going to make it even there guess not
really going to hit me at the Double Alt
God damn I was stood three of your ships
almost
what's a loan and you came up with him until
I take out a sniper but he's on our side
he's just an idiot
hey hey Scott 14 kills and five deaths and
he still wants all the items I don't give me
this give me them lines breaker I must have
everything I want all the power
yeah we can still easily lose this
it's not all that turned onto It Ain't Over
Til It's Over man it is not over until it's
over how is this queen of pain not playing
this well she's a queen of pain should have
been way better than that sniper interview
at this time in Mooresville tomorrow is just
like so she might still have them are must
be like really really bad
yeah so
this is why we play this game last night we
made a story about 40 minutes and I got I
kicked ass cuz I would just stay back here
and just kept holding everybody
I kind of wish I didn't have is Gotti now
are we good though
I should do a no boots build for her
into turbo the turbo Nobu Nobu its build for
a Nature's kicks ass like totally outruns
everybody else
do do I will take mid lane
I'll be bait hey go Christy go queen of pain
you go girl who's that sniper or something
to get his ass kicked
the sniper is full of hubris he is going to
go sell stuff kicked
222 hey look I automatically went up for no
reason
Federation oh shit I got to get in there
God damn it I can't go anywhere near there
though
Zusi Lucy I'm home
get him get him get him get him get him get
him get him yay team
oh shitoh shit how is a drought still alive
they're team for my team I told you we're
going to we're going to lose this
hey look they're attacking a backdoor thing
cuz they're idiots
come on you can do a queen queen go for it
so it's not going to end well
now how can end well for our favorite fan
I probably going to need a full-blown we
could be at this point I didn't think I was
but I definitely am
they just laughed at my old mare didn't do
that much damage
do to do to do to do to do to do to do
what you do here are they up yeah there's a
few people it's anybody empty people Woods
I tried to get you boots I hope I push
Crystal
Chris Rock Crystal I could actually do a
pretty good rat right now
cuz I have I have all this extra shit why
you pausing game
holyshit I'm done with this game
okay I got I got drop skills now I'm telling
you who doesn't want I just got to look how
pretty that is
I have Scotty is so fun that actually is not
in the game you know that means it means
that all the other people get get more XP
and they Advance faster when somebody
abandons like that sometimes it's the best
thing that ever happened to your team
how's that for them snowballs man that is
some big ass snowballs
what the fuck this is not a good team fight
I'm going to tell you right now
the same fight is not a good team fight
I meant after I was going to kill me yep saw
that coming
I'm telling you we're going to lose this
because you're being stupid chasing them
into their jungle is fucking stupid
Scotty I have Scotty
seriously chasing them into their chasing
them into their jungle was fucking stupid we
deserve to lose for that one decision all by
itself
that was so fucking stupid they have full
vision in their jungle and we decided to run
into there just cuz
yeah cuz you're pushing cuz you're a fucking
idiot here comes the sniper blaming
everybody else as usual as usual
no yeah
I was going to run in and die one of the
time 8 minutes
statistics I'm not leaving home home base
they can kiss my ass
stop fucking chasing them into their own
you're going to die sniper
this
usually I get for staff to
and I'll snap you got all the items dude
come on dude you got why don't we push me it
instead
you can't cuz you want the kills cuz
you'recuz you're cuz you're sniper
come on you didn't even right click them all
they were 20
not even a fuking right click
nice why are you doing sniper he got Scotty
it that's not going to end well
oh he got when did he get Stanek oh he's got
satanic nice alright we're okay then
yeah if you got the static is good oh God
you're so good
he dropped the gym cuz he's a fucking idiot
unless you drop agenda in
that necklace to Stivers telling the Zeus
like why didn't you Thunderclap Zeus and you
could have killed him when I got was almost
dead and is absolutely right
ring around the map taking these yeah
we're just friends here they keep sucking me
into this shit though
I need I need for Stuff I do I need for
staph
I ain't trickin if I actually but for staff
is safer
that's never a queen is so dead
hey Queen why don't you go take the teepee
point so someone doesn't teepee behind you
and kill you oh I know cuz you don't know
how to play DotA
seriously that TV point is open right there
go take it go take the teepee point before
you pushed a single step more
are you going to get ganked does the person
that has to be in right there and then going
to be like this and I'm going to kill you
is it going to do that McQueen is so dead
The Queen Is Dead I I don't want to leave
the base
I was going to Jungle why are you attacking
their jungle again don't start a team
fighting the fucking jungle
oh my God you guys are so stupid and I'm
going to get blame cuz we're not in the team
fight
stop fucking fighting him and then you try
to make a phone at 7 microphone okay help
you hear them. You know instead of you
blowing your ears out I'm sorry that was
like way too loud to me
dude this is stupid stop chasing it okay if
we're together we might be okay
I listen to say it to their face all right
wait wait
well I got some kills in I did I did good
things I did good things with that
I not good enough come on side for you got
this boy
I can't get you now oh shit
are you taking God damn
there we go where
I got to keep my back I have to keep my back
I don't want to risk I want to risk it
I would dare say that that that my old and
that last team fight tilted the scales a
little bit I will dare say that
oh you're so dead goodbye please can we win
now
cuz I want to play Nature's I can do more
damage some more Carnage
my guy was he got Hey look
I can come to the party now also my Ulta's
up
I have work just in case we need them how
can I be there cuz I didn't fucking take the
MIT god dammit Noobs
Noob noob you guys are scared now huh
everybody's dead and you guys are running
away all right well I'll just hang in the
jungle then since you obviously don't care
everybody's fucking dead and why don't you
guys finish the push
who is that can I go do some words and end
up dying God
I know
oh my God I can summon a demon
the end of you if I'm scared I don't want to
die
I don't want to die we're just too pretty to
we're just too pretty to die
yeah it did feel the scales finally finally
otherwise they would have if he if he had
stayed we probably they probably would have
had a better chance they could have one that
easily
yeah they didn't want it but they didn't
look at that chiseled Jaw look at that
chiseled Jaw
we are just too pretty to die
able to go we're just too pretty to die
oh no I hope my career didn't crash ssss app
look at that are slow so glad we have that
sniper oh my God we've been so much of
trouble
to do that wasn't him super impressive game
but it was okay the typical snapper turtle
game typical snapper turtle game
I know
I bet I know I'm saying
and snipers are always allowed their snipers
in your Ricky
if I can win the battle of the law so where
the hell yeah we did not deserve that win at
all
we should have totally lost that they made
so many stupid or strategic decisions like
really stupid decisions and those decisions
were led by the sniper by the way
let's Force blind in their jungle and then
have a team fight over there I'm sure that's
a great idea
yeah unfortunately I'm stuck in this lovely
why do you think I love nature problem so
much because nature profit can play a
strategic game no matter what the fuck the
team does
you start playing dated a few days ago
snipers broken turbo for sure yeah there's a
few characters that are really broken and
turbo snipers broken turbo and teenagers is
broken and turbo and as if you here as if
you're playing Turbo you just do it because
it's funnier Ultra cool if you can pull it
off and
and that would include coddle I've seen
cuddles like carry Turbo Games before
turbo is a different game Turbo is not do do
they got you fooled all the characters of
the same and all the maps the same but it's
not the same game
Turbo DOTA is not DOTA that's why they know
Oster Crystal again I miss you I miss you
but we pick if there's a bunch of ocean it
Mr Brownie should I pick Ricky just for the
fun of it
stream sniping I think of you all the time
yeah they do I've had to happen before
because they're watching me and they say are
you going to pick up Ava and I go watch it
because there's tiny little penis people who
don't really give a shit about things like
having a good game because it's a good game
and they actually have skill it's because I
just want to win they don't care they just
like they're so young they don't care I just
want to win all that matters is if they win
it's it's
they don't care how they win they just want
to win that's what I'm fixing a and Ricky
insurance
oh and I can't give me mid ain't giving men
to the person giving up all the gold that's
for damn sure this is a sign of an absolute
moron
absolute moron let's are gold completely run
out I'm a moron and because I left my gold
run out fast n o I love turkeys and turbo
take these intervals hilarious it's also
super painful this drought doesn't even know
what MidFirst god-awful reason we going to
lose or going to lose but I'm going to have
fun I'ma tell you right now we're going to
have fun we're going to have fun but we're
going to fucking lose this game I can all
the signs are already there
blue Argonaut picking heroes in time
we don't have any push Heroes where all
magic Heroes
do any better than this is that oh my God a
spirit breaker shit we have a bounty and a
spear breaker oh my God we are so fucked up
they have they have a slardar espirit a
bounty and a sniper
it doesn't matter we are totally going to
die
we're totally going to die
I'm just pretty clear right now I don't want
to die I want to play I want have a fun game
but we are totally going to get pumped as
they say I'm Firefly we're going to get
humped
all the Spanish going down
why did you stop chasing him you idiots why
did you say oh my God
they got the we would have had first one on
that bounty
we were there first one on that Bounty they
ran away
Obama has made this is very good news this
is very very good news
yeah come get me mrs. bounty mr. Bounty you
do that has found his idiot
isn't Auto attacker on top of all the other
stuff
I was going to be easy easy man oh my God
easy easy man here
yeah come on in and go into the tower drive
just to get your dumb ass gold and greedy
little shit
that's a great idea Bounty do it again
please say I don't bother getting any
lawsuits
yeah come chase me some more
is Tony Hunters an idiot
he's like an idiot a total idiot what is
even think he's doing he's probably
his is probably like eight years old I
should shut up
Susie's probably just a little kid he's not
an idiot he's just doesn't know he's doing
come on come on buddy yeah I can ride under
the tower that's what I wanted yeah you get
that goal now you're going to pay for his
buddy
he's not stupid he's he just doesn't have a
play he thought that he would be cool cuz
he's got a disability I should have been
getting freeze a lot earlier I would be on
in this dude I'm already level five
oh yeah now you haven't busy yeah you go
bounty
you go girl who is that that cercana
I probably shouldn't do that it's not worth
it usually has usually not worth it
I'm out what does that mean you're
teleporting out
oh no Bounty oh no whatever will I do
what is Stanford doing anything yet I can
report him I don't know what he's doing
it did you delete it
come on boots I need my boot so is his
bounties going to get it go get a Kill
yeah that was too close though I got to say
that was seriously close that way I got
boots now
that was way too close for my comfort
I'm on my mom, mom yeah we need to protect
against magic damage
uh oh
he's got to be so hard right now oh my God
like what is this Crystal doing
I fully expected to die on that one I did he
was just like panicking
I should have totally died on that last one
yeah good
I've heard this dive relieved I guess we won
Maybe
I also got up
I should probably go support my team I have
no Mana though uh oh
oh that's right hey maybe he'll get me
finally you got me yay Bounty good job
finally
what is all my team going where is only team
going
holy shit I don't know kills on our team and
then they leave really
where is Clint Hitchcock
oh my God
damn it
he's going to get even with me I'm still
tagged though
yeah I can't fight I'm sorry I cannot fight
against the spirit and a bounty while I'm
tagged I'm going to try though
why don't you go there yet I guess Lionel
fast my Google's up
yeah I know you like I have Scotty or some
shit I need like some like a 90 P boots or
something
yeah they're going to be pissed cuz they're
going to have to win it they're not going to
think of you mad at me cuz I'm not
abandoning
it didn't get nukes No it didn't I have work
a and
I'm still going to win employment in watch
me watch me win
always I got everybody I'm going to win
because I'm going to force them to win the
hard way
that's how I win that is how I win
how to make sure that Manny doesn't tag me
that's like the worst thing of all right now
go fast my gold comes up for doing nothing
cuz it's just me
do to do to do to do to do to do to do
I need to be thank you all right there's my
old
all right who is that purple alright that's
alright damn about writer
oh that's alright okay we were Bounty I
wanted to show his face again
come on show your face County how can I kill
who's squishy who is squishy
I like ice free squishy also there's a blue
guy there
I'm going to get tagged I do this we get
tagged it's too dangerous
I can be super careful
that's fine God damn I just got I just went
up like five levels
I know I got all the heck home
I mean wait
just giving me I just have to wait for my
olds or get some kills
they can if they push me they're good at
62nd if it's been way too much time
God damn I got marked I got marks
forget Mark is super dangerous to sniper can
hit me with his old
that was the one in dude it is like I'm not
going to kill Chris I'm going to kill this
girl I don't get girls or something
oh hey
oh hey you're going to die again van is
going to die again is going to die again oh
damn
he almost did they almost did how is he in
visitor in our base though all right I think
I know what's next after after I after I get
my shield after I get my supper I'm going to
get me to get another
I get my scepter I drank it the scepter I
mean I'll get the invisible o c I got to act
now I can buy Gerard to from nice and
yeah I know where the shed and I should play
the other Heroes dammit women do not
damn it he was just sitting there waiting
that's not fair
Camper City camper he actually bought a
Rapier
please let me kill him to get the Rapier
please let me kill him to get the rain. Oh
my God he's such an idiot
is it said every eight-year-old aspires to
every nine-year-old aspires to I don't want
to play this hero and get a Rapier soon as I
get lots of money
wait wait wait stop yet I got my thing up
all right here we go
god dammit
so awesome
where's my guy where's my guy around
is it oh shit I'm up again
it was wrong when I get at 2
touchdown it's here somewhere there's like a
reindeer and I can't see him LOL
now sent her a text
you cannot make that shit up did you did you
see did you see with this with his with the
cowshed
after after taking 15 minutes 15 minutes to
finish a full of Bandon game and giving up
Rapier they finally take the ancient and the
first thing he says is wrecked
oh my God I want to remember every one of
these names because I can't wait to play
with them again I cannot wait to play them I
got it specially Tesla just say you're my
friend thank you so much for playing against
us
it's so funny wrecked it who is it the
direct direct what is their username
house moving erection oh yeah they're
obviously 9yrs old- you and BP
oh my God
hey look I got an honorable mention Bounty
Hunter was MVP drops Rapier dies the crystal
floor X mid
Evie.
Play this game is as long as it's just so
funny it's so funny people get so into it
oh I got to take a break that was hilarious
that was a fun fun game for me it doesn't
look like everybody every other measure they
be like oh my God that's horrible I like I
had a blast
every one of those matches getting it down
essential oil safe people rushed it only
does it not going to yeah it's like
no it's it's a meme it's like such a meme
now you know I got to pick it in visitor I
get a real fast as I can
it's just so funny the way they play I
that's that's why I played turbo cuz at a
low and them are because it's not really
trolling I actually enjoy it but it's it's
just so much fun
and it's just really fun it's crazy it's
crazy
yeah for my graph look at that man we came
pretty close to winning we would have won if
everybody say
it's not sweaty that's for sure though this
a turbo
I don't I don't place what he did do that
like regular do that for that reason
go have fun do something useful with your
time don't watch me
no seriously I mean it don't watch me
laughing. I'm trying to kill the time before
dinner time I am actually enjoying my time
it's been a fun fun time off so
so I've been an issue again though yet
so technically we lost that game god dammit
I could have left instead of having a count
against me instead of counting against me oh
no whatever will I do
what
yeah
doo doo doo doo to do
what was the streaming right now anybody fun
Zig and zag stuff
oh head streaming oh shit
you're going to hear hat in the background
I'm sorry I want to hear what he has to say
oh my God is a they're horrible
come on natures wait somebody already
disconnected
how do we deploy manage things you got the
Management console but you also have two
other ways to get in late are you guys going
to think this is boring but
go watch het guys go watch Head tennis don't
watch me watch hat
I'm putting hat on my alternate stream
allow you to only see just me or is the only
talking in the right
the right speaker I think he's only talking
in the
I think he's only talking in the right
speaker but I don't know
God I want to come back and just watch this
I have to wait though
I'll have to come back and watch this little
stream I don't cuz I'm going to mess it up
if I don't
let's get it stomp here and then we'll go
from there how about that
I don't need a pause
we're going to totally stop this game is
really really obvious
why is going to bed I thought I'd gone mad
why are you coming top oh my God it is
alright so
2 2 2 2 2
oh he killed my my guy
sure sure sure sure sure let's get back to
where we started from
sf9 Jungle is a turbo we don't jungle
turbo doesn't jungle you do turbo and you do
jungle in the turbo but it's not nearly the
same
that's all I want to say about that yeah
9 creeps are like at least as good
it's a totally different meta that's why
it's so different
oh no they're going to kill my other guys
I going to kill my guys yeah
turn on turbo trailer really change the game
a lot actually
but forgot it yeah I can try I can try to
answer it
ancient good shot dude excellent
you think if you do this you got to make
sure you got to make sure you control your
your creeps you do not want to hand over
your creeps XP to them if they get low
it's like really important you don't do that
paint horse betting systems nice
a risk and assembly I don't know anything
about it I really love it but I want to know
more about it I am so I feel I feel like
learning RS5 and assembly is a fantastic
thing where did
yeah I think that would be fantastic
I kind of wish I was learning that I was
jealous
Stryker Yeah Yeahs Dennis about it too I
would go on YouTube and I would ask Dennis
what you think it what he thinks about it
Dennis is a bigger is five guy right wrist
be
I got that got killed I'm going to hear
about that
Dennis is on YouTube history of all time
you should definitely go watching if you're
interested in him bedded
I would I would like really make sure you
get over there and watch him
shit
here comes my guys
yeah we definitely
Frank's got more experience with that than I
ever would
shit here comes the game
at his age is really having a blast this is
kind of fun to watch
ancients one of the most entertaining here
is a play in the whole game and my opinion
Dune
I guess we're going mid
this is awesome
cha cha boom
does the Asus cave is crazy
this game is nuts o DC from breadboards wow
did you see the guy who made his own
circuits in his house
he constructed his own transistors in his
house
it's pretty amazing
do to do dangerously wandering about the
jungle with Reckless while demanding
Lego bb8
hi what are you doing I like pictures
2 2 2 2 2 2 2
the Empire podcast interview at 6 great
thank you for posting that Frank very useful
stuff
oh shit I'm done
God damn this guy's getting so many kills
does it say
awesome Miss ancient is ancient is like look
at is 7 + 0 is ancient
this is so cool I makes me want to play it
again
yeah he's playing really well
yeah yeah I mean in Turbo ancient is really
fun if you can do it I'm good and I'm not
really that good I love ancient it's really
fun to try to play like that but it takes
really crazy good skill to do that
you can't blame me for your newfound
addiction it's Friday night I clean Friday
Night Lights Friday night rates
you know here's a let me just give you a
little tip here Pudge next time you see he's
so dead I cannot help him at all
the Chancery for her
I'm going to just give you a little gay
maybe tonight you can use this is it this is
keeping me awake so that since I have dinner
I'm going to be back and I'm going to be
going to be back at the Cooper Nettie's
coating stuff
can yeah so I give me some some fresh for
some motivation there
you should try this you should try this
turbo Nature's build
it's crazy it's a no boots build that I
invented in and it kicks ass I haven't lost
with it yet so far
mine god dammit
Scotch Heritage God damn you if you still
the only kills it's fine it's it's hilarious
every time
seriously this build is insane
why is that I'm still afraid of blood Circle
even though I know it's not going to hurt me
I am
I'm still afraid of it going to check in,
I'll give you my crystals and 80's Daedalus
will you just hurry up
I wants my datiles they're going to come
mark my words oh my my my dog is going to
get killed here we go
now I have carrots now kritzer in the house
and with o here comes like Supercuts
tell me this build is out of control it is
really out of control
watch I shall I shall indicate what timing
he's dead
and I don't have boots so I can't Jason down
Foods
I need this later God damn it I got too much
rumor
that's later I need this later I'm not
having this dump I wanted but it's pretty
good
what's an assist though cuz of AAA the same
as carrying the most kills
oh yeah that's funny give me my dad so give
me my dad so
WhatsApp from devops the gamer I don't know
I just am me
no boots on MP maybe now maybe in Turbo but
not in a full game
let's kick it kick it scary but why don't
you Alton dude
not worth it I guess huh Daddy's got satanic
and everything
I could probably kill that Timber but I
don't want to risk it
I guess so I'll go back to fight fight the
good fight
yes remove Telford cool down
I guess we're done God I'm so slow
I'm so slow
what is that but where you going dude
that's not going to end well a punch keeps
getting called out man
that's what happens when your AAA is your
killer
shall I help with that God damn this a this
a is amazing
now it's just rat a rat I know
rat rats DotA
oh yeah I want to Luna Mirada
26 that's a tough one I wonder if I could
take him
I guess so
that wasn't too hard I guess the answer to
that is yes I can take them
I'm going to dtp one hitting creep camps
oh yeah this is when you just fucking
because I have unlimited movement I go
anywhere on the fucking board
it's like a three-headed I like I three head
that you cry
it's just insane it's almost unfair I know
it
here shoot there's three of them
I don't know if I can do anything there
that's is where we go insane this system are
we joking saying I told you the salvages
like I do. What else would I can't I get a
song just for the funk of it
risotto it's coming rizzotto's coming
butterfly not a him
let me know I mean I got so much locked down
now made it to hear we're going to get words
next should I go kill that guy if I can't
quite do that one but then you just roll
them all game is cuz like I can
I just like knock the wave out and it's move
around so fast they can't touch you is
seriously can't touch you they have no idea
where you are
just in case they're in our jungle would you
be stupid
and now and now the rest of us all we're
going to go get
now we're going to go get we're going to do
deep words now now we do do boards
and the game is like over
now this is a name Amara this is Turbo and
it's and it's really lonely no more yeah
I'm going to take off
Dee Ford's
God damn it I didn't get either kill that
sucks
I think you guys are cool
if I didn't and they are expecting me to
carry this cuz AA can't carry it from now on
yeah we lost we would win if I hadn't died
over there and I had and I we would have won
I'm pretty got a refund and get the food it
does not count
nice
oh man I totally arid on that
well that was stupid for thinking of it now
that was like a real fail I hit three
different keys that is wrong key every
single one every single he was wrong
do you like this
I'm going to try to get all the tracks if
they do that too loose they will lose if
they do that
I mean I still have it
no idiots go get those racks and then get
the towers I don't know why people don't
know this I have one this so many times
all you need to do to start hitting the mid
Towers is take one set of tracks
people think they have to take all the
things before they can hit the ancient they
don't
the best way to win this is it that people
don't know this you take one Tower to racks
and you go straight to the mid towers and
take that ancient you don't have to get the
other Towers
there's no requirement to do that
hill hill hill when that
did you get that kill you piece of shit all
right fine I save your ass when you get the
kill
there by myself Arsenal is this we're
getting really close though
any luck out man dead
running from the blood secret that was
really awesome
maybe push mid I don't know what do you
think
where you going are you fucking jungling a
level 30
level 30 jungling why would you jungle at
why are you not touching me They're All Dead
what the fuck are you doing
oh my God we deserve to lose this
yeah not when they're old dead every single
mother team is dead and we are juggling
oh my God
why are they jungling what the fuck are
these people doing
I got off my keys god dammit
I was close
why are we not pushing why are we not
pushing
not racist
I don't give a shit about the rest I want to
go have dinner woot woot
takes the ancient all right that was fun was
not as fun as it could have been but it was
funny
it was I'm telling you I don't lose the
Nature's that's was that the sixth straight
game of no losses when there's this this
particular build
it's because they can Farm the shit out of
everything you can like yeah it's a risotto
yes send me that photo and I can I can
probably doing some other things probably
time for me to leave though cuz I'm getting
jittery from DOTA too much it too much
adrenaline has a good game
everybody have fun let me see what I mean
it's like 15 of us so if you ever do. Let's
go find some of the raid in the DOTA
category Shelly
oh that's nice as I swear I'll get you some
commands here yeah I'd say a definite yet to
come in
I mean there was such a nice all rounds
break a team
let me know. It's all right let's go
let's read
I don't know who to read though so let's go
find somebody in the DOTA category
categories how is Stoughton on the category
is that an a category
games I was I wrong this way
I don't feel wanted to see note in but
I mean I don't know who these people are but
when you go ahead and eat him
yeah sorry
top donator